très complexe il faut que kasparov
de toute façon
joue le coup
tours 8
échec
c'est forcé et après roy 17 qui est fort
c'est aussi tout reprend tour roy cette
tour bouge probablement en des huit pour
protéger le fou des deux
et la partie
il a pas l'air il a pas l'air satisfait
kasparov il n'a pas l'air satisfait il
n'a pas l'air satisfait kasparov là dans
cette position après cavaliers prend f2
au 40e coup joué par cramique il faut
absolument que kasparov joue tours 8
échec il n'a pas le choix
c'est une nouvelle partie qui commence à
ce moment là c'est une nouvelle partie
qui commence une finale
le 40e coup est passé des joueurs ont
été crédités maintenant tous les deux
d'une heure supplémentaire pour jouer
les vingt coups suivants krainik est
passé par une petite crise d'autant
puisque il lui restait 22 secondes avant
de jouer son 40e coup enfin au moment où
il a joué son 40e coup donc il devait
être attentifs à la kasparov est en
train de noter le coup suivant il n'a
pas l'air satisfait notre ami kasparov
y essayer de se remémorer ce qui a pu se
passer non oh là là là il a pas l'air il
n'a pas l'air content du tout du tout du
tout
que va-t-il se passer
toro buts et cheikh al air forcé
ap
non ne pas
tous
non là après la prise de temps là il
faut il faut reprendre ses esprits
donc là on à l'échiquier de
démonstration qu'on n'a pas demandé mais
pourquoi pas ce qu'on peut revenir sur
le plan de kasparov
notre ami
et si kasparov
qui n'a pas l'air satisfait c'était une
partie où il a tenté de gagner par tous
les moyens il n'a pas réussi pour
l'instant à démontré une supériorité
clair mais la partie restait très tendue
très compliqué c'est une finale c'est
une finale avec peu de matériel à
kasparov viennent de donner une tour il
faut absolument la menace de kramnik
probablement c'est de jouer cavalier en
a eu quatre donc il faut probablement
voilà tours 8
ça y est il a joué tours 8 notre ami
kasparov obligé et là attention
évidemment il faut pas prendre la tour
puisque si les noirs prennent la tour 8
évidemment le pion f7 reprend en faisant
dame et là évidemment les blancs ont un
avantage énorme et gagnon il faut
surtout pas jouer ça il faut jouer roi
petite subtilité petite subtilité de
finale roy 17 et après tout reprendre
tour roy en a eu sept avec peut-être
il faut que kramnik joue absolument 3,17
et après tout reprendre tour recettes
joué le coup tour des huit obligeant
kramnik apprendre le pion à vii et le
problème c'est qu'après roi prend
cavaliers le coup de crâne x et 4 ces
trois ici voilà c'est une possibilité
évidemment ce n'est pas encore ce qu'ont
joué les joueurs alors pourquoi on voit
pas l'image en bas à droite
je comprends pas on devrait voir l'image
en bas à droite a le
stéphane
soient devenues indisponibles donc alors
voilà effectivement nous reprenons après
la fin du zaï note gary kasparov vient
de jouer tour huit échecs et nous allons
passer sur l'échiquier de démonstration
pour bien comprendre tous les enjeux de
cette position voilà nous revenons à la
position la vraie après tours 8 échecs
krainik va jouer ici c'est très probable
roy 17
alors attention que se passe-t-il
chronique devrait jouer le roi en
dessert là il est dans une phase en fait
où il se remet en condition il vient de
passer des menottes c'était pas facile
donc effectivement ici il n'a pas le
choix mais il essaie de bien d'évaluer
les conséquences de roy 17 savoir un
petit peu où il en est savoir ce que
vaut la position il ne veut pas jouer
roi 17 même si c'est le seul coup trop
vite il n'est pas pressé il préfère
prendre son temps
alors que stephen revient et oui j'ai
fait de croiser notre ami kasparov dans
les couloirs chronique évidemment à
jamais roi 17 donc évident donc là on en
comprend maintenant l'idée du coup c42
kramnik de tout à l'heure ça va faire
partie nulle et le voilà ça devrait
faire partie de ça devrait faire partie
de quoi que c'est des procédés pion qui
vont en dame tout reprend tout reprend
tour alors que les chèques électroniques
des los boys deviens fou
l'espace d'un instant pour caen tour a
été joué
rose 7
comme de vrais cheveux roux 1,7
alors que stéphane vient de croiser
kasparov
quand celui ci allait aux toilettes
peut-être tu peux nous en dire un peu
plus sur la façon dont gary se dépasser
alors qu'il est déjà de retour à l'écran
était fait et tout à fait inédit le très
vite il est dit il pas filtrer vide
alors qu'est ce que tu penses ici du
couffo h 6 après 3 cette fois ci ça leur
foi chitsaz de menaces oreiller en fait
c'est l'inconvénient de secours c'est
que si la tour bouge le plan à vii sera
perdue ah oui alors de regarder là où je
pense qu'on va faire le point parce que
a priori kasparov devrait réfléchir
beaucoup dans cette position qui n'est
pas simple où il a plusieurs
possibilités
il peut jouer il peut bouger sa tour à
peu près où il veut soit la mettre en
des mythes pour défendre le fou des deux
ça c'est une possibilité
ces 8 soit la date limite pour attaquer
le tueur c'est cette ça c est une autre
possibilité de coupe aussi pour nous ça
marche pas ça marche pas parce que le
tour c'est 8
il ya roi prend f7 alors tour s'est vite
nous allons regarder
alors pourquoi déjà faut-il qu'il bouge
ça tours et bien simplement parce que
celle ci est attaquée par le roi
donc il faut bouger la tour et perdre au
passage le plus obscène c'est
obligatoire nao kramnik donc a été malin
voyons par exemple tour s'est vite c'est
une possibilité
roy reprend pions f7 c'est un peu forcé
garry kasparov prend l'option c7 faisant
échec au roi le roi de crown il doit
bouger par exemple reviendrait sur la
case g6 oui pour un pour contrer les
pions blancs où il réplique on a aussi
ce pour aider des pieds noirs
alors là c'est une question de goût
question c'est un choix à faire
ici effectivement cette position
compliquée est ce que les noirs sont pas
mieux finalement est ce que les blancs
ne sont pas mieux que tous les fans ou
les blancs je ne sais pas je n'en sais
rien quelque chose est en train de
m'échapper dans cette position je ne
comprends pas ce qui se passe sur
n'importe quel coup droit je joue le
couffo en 3 et là je n'arrive pas à
comprendre pourquoi les noirs ne serait
pas perdant dans cette position il est
tout simplement qu'un valide 10,3 oui
mais ce n'est qu'un coup sa qualité 3
c'est complètement peremans cette
pression stéphane d'après tout repenser
4 et là effectivement donc là mais
probablement alors là mais probablement
quoi après tours sémites s'efforcer
cramique doit prendre au fc sète mais
tout à fait clair un visa vraiment pas
le choix
toi prends pions et châteauroux
maladroit aussi ce droit aussi c'est une
autre possibilité
c'est probablement celle qui sera
adoptée par vladimir kramnik dans le cas
de cette éventualité
6 et maintenant il ne faut pas se
tromper il ne faut évidemment pas joué
trois points f2 qui n'a aucun sens
après tout reprend des deux échecs et
tour revient en c2 c'est une mule facile
pour les noirs il faut ici jouer bien
entendu le couffo 3 qui offre des
chances de gain réel puisque après
cavalli détroit on joue tous reprochions
c4
et là effectivement ramener doit tout
jouer sur son cul bombé qui cela dit est
bien placé oui puisque le cavalier
prendre contrôle bien les cases noires
le cavalier contrôle bien la case
élection de kasparov ont l'air plus loin
de l'action par exemple b5
comment on fait pour arrêter le pion le
pion on va l'arrêter ici il n'ya pas de
n'y a pas de problème on peut jouer tour
échec et tours derrière le pion position
très difficile pour vladimir kramnik
donc si on revient à la position
actuelle que les joueurs ont sur
l'échiquier
après trois sets garry kasparov
vraisemblablement on va jouer pour ces 8
si on compare à l'idée de revenir non
attention on va d'abord comparé évident
mais soyons plus plus constructif il
faut regarder le contour des mythes pour
comprendre qu'après avoir point f7 si on
joue on apprend cavaliers on pense qu'on
a une caisse de plus ça a l'air vrai
mais ici il ya le coup c'est cap c3 qui
récupère le fou facilement puisque celui
ci est cloué donc là pas de problème
alors maintenant caspar va jouer
vraisemblablement sa part est maintenant
une certitude
tours s'est vite voilà dans cette
position là
il va aller enseigner c'est très
probable on peut regarder peut-être des
images sur kasparov qui va jouer ce coup
je pense vraiment qu'il va le faire je
sais pas ce que tu en penses tétouan
mais je ne vois pas ce qu'il peut jouer
d'autre à part tour s'est vite s'il veut
continuer cette partie pour le gain du
tiw mans pour ces 8
et là je crois qu'en fait kasparov a pas
l'air sur son visage on a on voit bien
qu'il n'a pas l'air convaincu du tout de
la supériorité de sa position il a dû
voir plus loin
c'est quand même une position
incroyablement compliqué
pour ces huit à l'air
à l'ordre du jour donc la fouer 3 qu'est
ce qui se passe sur fou aux 3 1 il a
joué tour c8 et oui effectivement
kasparov a joué tour ses huit donc la
chronique n'a pas le choix
la menace cfct fuite dame est oui alors
sur l'échiquier de démonstration peut
être on peut montrer qu'après fct fuite
le pion sur transforme en dame donc ce
n'est absolument pas acceptable
le seul coup dans cette position
ces trois champions et cette voix là ça
il a joué crânement tout de suite
chronicles a joué dans la province est
donc la tour prend ses aises el cheikh
la granny doit réfléchir pour jouer soit
roi g6 wah wah e61 des deux groupes
probablement réussisse je sais pas 3g si
c'est plus fin une chose est sûre la
partie ne va pas s'arrêter de sitôt
c'est une position très technique il a
l'air comme en corse maroc l'un des
sports il est là il a l'air serein là
qu'on propose sa tête dernière impérial
oui effectivement
kasparov sur cette image a l'air assez
pourrait même saisir en pense qu'il a
gagné la partie
je sais pas je sais pas je ne sais pas
si ce n'est de très logique de vladimir
kramnik l'info à trois fouilles 3 va
être joué très très vite par garry
kasparov
c'est clair après 3,6 il va je me fous
et 3 c'est une certitude voilà ça y est
soit 3,23 bien entendu avec donc
avantage blanc faut être un net avantage
blanc mat avantage blanc puisque krainik
donc doit bouger son cavalier qui est
attaqué
kasparov se lève ça il a tout vu il est
parti il est vraiment c'est d'un banal
donc la cram dit que non mais kramnik
point de corde il peut jouer qu'à
valider un peut-être un avec l idée c 3
ses sa annonce qui a aidé un ça va pas
il a tout repensé cap quand même
peut-être annonce qui est bien c'est
mieux puisqu'on veut garder le pion le
plus avancé cop et si calédonie au
prince et 4 et non puisqu'il y aurait
trois des cinq as non pourquoi
à cause de tour des quatre échecs des
rois ah oui offrande est tout à fait
tout à fait ses choux donc qui a aidé un
ici assure-t-on pensée 4 il y à tour
projet 2 et voilà oui voilà superbe
superbe voilà donc surtout je pensais
qu'à dans cette position ah oui mais
est-ce que c'est à huy à vis et
travaille sa cagnotte et fatma forte
mais c'est au moins un âne on est mieux
le prendre
on n'est pas obligé de prendre pour l on
perd le plus de le freiner les noirs
vont être mieux c'est non plus renoncer
nul c nul donc ici sa partie du la
partie du lot
après 3h une cale il prend de 3 tours et
châteauroux 4 échecs en récupère le
cavalier saigne ça c'est ton analyse met
un peu en âge on est très très loin de
très très loin de fournir ces prolos
perdront cette finale a peut-être
perdant alors voilà donc c'est nul mais
peut-être perdre c'est nul mais
peut-être qu'avant donc les doutes
subsistent en tout cas qu'à valider un
dock ram knicks a l'air d'être le
meilleur
pourquoi parce que si enfin bref ton
français 4 n'est pas possible les blancs
doivent donc prendre l'option des six
oui mais sinon les noirs les noirs
j'oublie 5
et maintenant et maintenant c'est là que
ça devient sympa on joue le coup c3 c3
et c2 est à l'ordre du jour et ses 2 va
arriver avec une position extrêmement
compliqué ouais mais attention parce que
le cavalier blanc le calais nord sort
plus le cahier l'heure de sortir et les
pièces sont coincés dans leur que les
blancs ont joué g4 g5 h 4 h 5
leroy ouvrage dourges évident ici
non c'est vrai dit si ces raids ces
raids c'est complètement raide après le
fou ou trois noms qui a fait maroc pas
pris une bonne option il va gagner en
renfort kasparov va gagner on a rien
compris à ce parti on n'a rien compris
cette partie je crois que là
kramnik sait qu'il a perdu non il n'a
pas perdu parce qu'il peut jouer l'envi
attention il le sait où il n'a pas perdu
normes il n'a pas perdu kramnik parce
que il est ok l'océan mais il peut
sacrifier son cavalier contre les deux
pions ah bon bon c'est d'ailleurs
stéphane très judicieuse que tu veux
dire puisqu'on peut envisager cabinet
prend pion à 3 oui mais malheureusement
qui est qu'on perdra encore et ça ne
marche pas oui non mais avec tour à 3 à
venir oui me aref de mailhac de ça ne
suffit pas l'idée c'était de jouer qui
est proche de troyes et tours ici mais
ça ne marchera pas donc comment travnik
va fait ainsi de cavaliers de crâne qui
arrive à prendre
d'une façon ou d'une autre les deux
pions blancs la finale touré fou contre
tours est une finale nul ne le met
maintenant c'est pas facile
est-ce qu'on peut crème blocus avec un
cavani tout il va en der aa
il est intense dans le village il tant
de grands achats kasparov ils avaient
plus loin qu'elle kramnik plus loin que
quoi de fond de plan b si ce fonds prend
b6 est très probable oui mais il n'a pas
vu que ces pièces sont coincés après
année ne sont pas tout à fait coincer il
peut jouer tour b 2
et après tomber trois peut-être une
certaine variante pas pierre paclet
quel est d un cabinet d un cahier d un
cavalier dépeint la parole n'a pas le
choix ce soir il va jouer vous combien
oui parce que sinon b5 et si les noirs
qui sont mieux donc là il faut prendre
le pion v6 donc pour l'instant que des
coûts forcé alors mettons l'échiquier de
démonstration fou prend pions b6 donc
que jouer pour avec les noirs avec des
noirs et bien non on peut aussi chasse
il fout on peut faire peut-être tomber
deux faire tomber deux ans que je le
tour ces deux également pour ces deux
bof c'est à dire que tous les deux il ya
fou des quatre équipes aux seins qui
pose un problème
donc ça c'est je crois que c'est clair
oui
donc fou prend b6 web
on attend que kasparov joue ça il a
l'air dubitatif mais il va voir semblant
de jeu et l'a ensuite il y aura
plusieurs coups possibles tour b 2 outre
ces deux ça sera au choix et la position
deviendra extrêmement compliqué voilà
donc là un petit bonjour à notre ami
bertrand bertrand qui tenteraient ne
nous regarder en direct et qui trouve
merveilleux le fait de pouvoir suivre ce
championnat du monde en direct vidéo
pour la première fois et bien bertrand
salut à toi et ça lui à toute la famille
voilà voilà donc petit message à
caractère informatif informatif faut
prendre et si ce qui n'a pas encore été
joué par gary kasparov qui va le jouer
c'est sûr y'a pas d'autres coups mais il
va le faire
bon oui nos médias qu'est ce qui a été
fait des jouets ses articulations
raisani la rb6 il n'y a aucun bluff dans
ce match garry kasparov de gagner contre
6 apparemment il est à eau
oh oh oh là qu'est ce qui se passe le
public aurait fait du bruit et ça aurait
gêné garry kasparov vol à la wii ça
arrive ça permettrait de devenir
ailleurs il a très très énervé mais
enfin il est quand même rassuré par sa
position
moi je crois que là il a le point en
poche et donc c'est pas mal pour caspar
parce que si ils égalisent aujourd'hui
ils posent des problèmes chroniques
c'est vrai parce que là ils démontrent
que sa défense mais il faut le revoir sa
défense berlinoise
non la défense berlinoise mais pas
revoir à mon avis aux saignées garry
kasparov savinaud la position du vampire
ouais il attend sa proie il est dans la
nuit dans l'obscurité
vous voyez le merveilleux décor de
bonnes games avec 1
ok on fond bleu très bien fait la cram
nick est en train de réfléchir ni madar
et voilà il il a l'air assez tranquille
quand même il a peu probablement vu des
petits trots des choses vu des choses
chroniques ou non mais non il n'y a pas
de carrière face à soi-même l'air bien
raide 1 c'était pas non non je pense
qu'il va falloir se résigner qu'est-ce
qu'il faut jouer ce kasparov est
vraiment très très fort les
complications il n'a pas du tout gâcher
la fête il a pris des risques dans cette
partie kasparov non mais si ces trois si
les noirs ou c3 et probablement les
blancs d'oeufs vous fout des quatre en
fait
c'est probable
il faut des quatre en fermant le
cavalier noir et ensuite h 5 h 4 h 56
quoique bon j'suis pas avoir quoi donc
également ramener le roi vert cavaliers
n'ont ici
travnik est à l'agonie
les pions blancs mine de rien qui sont
encore seulement deux cases quasiment de
départ j'ai deux filles h3c deux pions
blancs sont pas jouées samedi qu'à ses
deux pions blancs sont très forts c'est
eux qui vont décider de la partie c'est
à dire que la menace des blancs
évidemment c'est de pousser ses pions en
l'air a damé le problème des noirs c'est
que arrêté de publier c'est très
difficile alors qu'on aurait sur un
sommet kalenga gazier il avance son
bureau et c'est la faute là ça y est
chronique n'a plus aucune illusion dans
cette partie il est sûr qu'il est
perdant là il ne joue pas la défense la
plus précise il n'a pas envie d'agoniser
il ne veut pas prolonger une souffrance
de la carence a fait preuve d'une grande
maîtrise aujourd'hui là on retrouve un
kasparov affûté et ses 3 c'est fini et
je crois que tous les coups tous les
coups ont plutôt tendance à gagner
ça faisait longtemps que les deux
joueurs n'avaient pas gagné l'un contre
l'autre et là en trois parties boum boum
boum boum
tout à fait
difficile pour chronique il a réussi à
garder son avantage
c'est quand même non mais c'est pas fini
la partie est loin d'être fini on
habille kramnik va encore jouer parce
que il ya des chances encore et encore
des chances de sacrifier le cavalier
contre ses deux pions une façon d'une
autre un voilà c'est ça comme ça ils
cassent par met en branle servage validé
il joue le pion le plus éloigné ce qui
va obliger le roi noir aller vers ce
pion donc le roi noir pour 1 - épauler
ses pièces de l'autre côté le problème
des noirs aussi c'est que mais pour
pousser leurs pions noirs c'est
difficile parce que la tour en ces sept
contrôles très bien sûr l'attention
stéphane je vais arrêter tout de suite
puisque nous avons une déclaration
fracassante de l'ordinateur il y aurait
ici quelque chose d'exceptionnel et non
en fait non l'ordinateur six reprises et
s'est repris il a annoncé sa c2 oui ces
deux ici la menace c'est tour à un coup
très fort
donc il faut jouer donc vraiment levé
l'oréal ma mère vient vanter les pions
seydoux seront prises pour y remédier
aux risques et la lier aux trois échecs
à la découverte suffisant mais non il
faut donc jouer rouages de mal un pays
si ignorer ou tour b 2 cuil très fort
puisque le pion en h4 et ont acheté
après ça c'est un gros problème
le fou à peaufiner la food & 4 voix
c'est à décrire du x 7
il y a x 7 x 7 il ya tour de cette
stéphane et oui le pion est quand même
très avancées il ne faut pas le prendre
à la légère ce pion à wissant fois 7 à
tour 17
eric est sûre et donc donc reste donc
floue j'ai un tour c'est si c'est chez
ces six échecs qui perdrait ouais il
reste donc quoi elle reste donc floue
des quatre qui est une possibilité mais
tout raschke tourbe et quatre tours b 4
effectivement tombé 4 on n'en comprend
pas on en entendra ce qui se passe on ne
comprend pas pourquoi 124 que six façons
on ne comprend pas c'est une simulation
toujours sur l'échiquier de
démonstration préfou des quatre fous des
quatre tours b 4 et là que se passe-t-il
bouge bien pourquoi jouer d'abord faut
des quatre la prévention c'est tout à
fait incroyable ici il n'ya plus
investir davantage si kramnik arrive à
prendre le pion h4 ça va être nul ça va
être nul ou presque a vu kasparov en
revoyant donc à rossi 7e coup ils jouent
h 4 il faut laisser la question qu'on se
pose c'est que se passe-t-il sur ces 2
qui menacent tour à un temps que le roi
est sur la première rangée on lastours 1
qui menacera c1 et surtout reprend ses
deux cavaliers ou trois échecs au roi à
la découverte
ici le coup de kasparov sembles force et
roire h2 sûr qu'on joue tourbe et deux
attaques le fou en v6 qui a pas beaucoup
de cases parce que le client de
délinquants trop le 3d f2 le cavaly des
infos je vais bouger un contrôle fausse
dessous gérer l'eau a tout simplement
alors sur fou j'ai un
le problème est le suivant sur fuji 1
son soutien
je crois qu'on pourrait jouer 3 f 5
voilà exactement c'est exactement ça et
on bloque les pions de garry kasparov
puisque maintenant s'ils cassent pas
rejouer war iii est bien ça me coûte
beaucoup plus cher que prévu
après tours b 3 échecs g3 et tour en c3
qui intercepte la tour blanche donc rien
n'est perdu pour kramnik mais non mais
ici ils sont grassement fait une gaffe
monumental c'est une c'est une bavure h4
sur une bavure en h4 serait une bavure
parce que surtout csn qui évidemment
après celle énoncée fois êtes il faut
s'informer 7 et 8 tomber cette escale à
la presse que l'incroyable se serait
produit stéphane est peut-être encore en
revirements de situation est ce que
trame il peut gagner cette partie mais
ce qu'ils avaient le choix
kasparov est-ce qu'il faut bien sûr
qu'il avait le choix est trouvé aux
rouages de tout de suite qu'ils étaient
bien supérieurs au roi et enfin beaucoup
de choses étaient supérieurs h théâtre
et kasparov s'est précipité et a oublié
un détail que évidemment cramique ne
ratera pas c'est sûr donc ces deux ces
deux menaces
allons-y pour la variante ces deux
menaces tour à tour un kif et dames
alors est-ce que kasparov peut envisager
dessous des 4 as oui quel sport peut
envisager sous des 4 et donc à ce que
fout des quatre c'est tout un tas de 1,4
sur coup d'éclat il n'y a pas et chacun
pris mais bon il est pas et chacun
attend
bah oui non mais tu auras 4 c'est très
ennuyeux alors allons-y mentionnons ce
qu'on est en train de raconter food et 4
c'est ce coup là voilà qui al'avantage
de contrôler la case un oui mais ici il
y a le coup droit dé 5,1 me wade c'est
qu'aussi et là on commence à arriver
avec le roi pour son bien et son roi
krainik la voyais autour de cet échec
oui mais ça va ça va pas du tout il ya
ce coup là très très chaud puisque le
sou ne peut pas garder en même temps la
case 1 et la case aux trois pour le
cavalier
bref conte problème alors là il faut
qu'on y reste sur cet échiquier
démonstration parce que ça devient très
critique si cram nique
après hkd jouent ces deux on ne voit pas
comment kasparov évite la nulle la vente
principal étant la suivante garry
kasparov souricière orages deux jours
est tombé deux attaques le fourbe et 6
qui n'a que très peu de cases sur food
et 4 on va récupérer qui ont h quatre
dealers fou j'ai un oncle ou le superbe
coup suivant roi f5 allant
positionnement neutraliser des pions
kasparov avec la pointe ce rouage 3 qui
manageait quatre échecs dont je tourbe
et trois échecs d'abord est sûre j'ai
trois tours c3 hélas le pion ces deux
qu'on n'attendait pas qu'on attendait
pas l'option tous a lancé deux irait
donc ça fait nul facile pour vladimir
kramnik donc alors ben je pense qu'on a
résumé à peu près la situation dise
incroyable alors que ce prof aurait fait
une gaffe qui as part of our a fait une
monumentale bavure
c'est incroyable qu'à of aurait
peut-être fait une gaffe mais bon
évidemment non juge avec nos petits nos
petits moyens et outils moyenne notre
niveau mais il n'en donnerai voilà il
semblerait que kasparov et dans cette
position fait une gaffe maintenant
est-ce que kramnik est-ce que chrome ni
va voir moi je pense que kramnik a déjà
vu il n'a pas l'air convaincu je sais
pas il a déjà vu ce qui se passe avec
ramener qu'il a forcément vu ce qui se
passait les crânes x est calculateur
hors pair ce n'est pas le premier venu
à ce niveau là les joueurs n'aura rien à
mes kasparov a bien raté quelque chose à
part aubert et tessa viennent de se
relâcher
c'est aussi ça arrive ça et loi quand on
a un avantage après le 40e coup après le
40e coup pouf on peut se relâcher et
reperdre d'un coup tous les avantages
accumuler oui tout à fait par contre
même s'ils craignent qu'elle sera sortie
à la nulle c'est comme une presque une
demi victoire pour kasparov puisqu'il
devra quand même ébranlés
fortement la défense de chroniques je ne
crois pas qu'ils ont peu qu'on puisse
dire ça à mon avis krasniqi a été très
tranquille dans cette partie il est
absolument pas eu de problème c'est
juste au moment où kramnik s'est
enflammée et s'est dit je vais peut-être
lui allé le chercher dans cette position
alors qu'il aurait pu faire très
facilement
mais comment tout simplement ne vont pas
à 5-4 il suffisait de ramener les pièces
phares leçons n'ont pas donné le pion à
chis tout ça c'était possible g dit
c'est dit je vais jouer nos contres jeu
au lieu de se dire je vais jouer la nuit
peut-être hélas donc si kramnik fait nul
c'est évidemment c'est évidemment un
sale coup pour garry kasparov
ça va lui casser le moral stéphane n'est
ce pas bien kasparov sera mal c'est une
équipe à sa portée
ah oui on ne joue pas ces deux ans c'est
incroyable incroyable un an qu'ils aient
omis la clôture ville incroyable
non ce qu'il a vu il a joué mais il n'a
pas joué et d'aller franc de la tour il
allait prendre la tour qui va faire avec
sa tour je ne sais pas ce qu'il avait
prévu de faire avec ça tout retour à 6
non non si peut-être tout incident
marque il ay un plein aussi tour à 6 les
lois le football est roi des 6 et après
je mets un tour en c6 hayatou racice
aussi tout à 6 alors où est la wallonne
la sela surtout à 6 on voit que 10 en
travelling toi c'est notre ami tour à
six tours à six jouets parc ramener
hewitt aura six chroniques trop fort il
a vu quelque chose
il a calculé quelque chose et il connaît
et il se lève tôt raciste et l'ascension
c'est dangereux
kasparov revient comme un fou et 80
provient est-ce que c'est pas dangereux
tour à six parce que si le fou bouger
l'eau on va vite voir cette olalalala
ces choses vous l'a craint au live-score
ont fait enlever une poussière de
l'échiquier attention il est plongé dans
réflexion tour à 6,2 g ni kramnik a vu
quelque chose dans une variante dans une
finale qui semblait perdu incroyable que
kasparov n'ai pas vu ça oh là là à
jackass c'est la plus grande gaffe que
j'ai jamais vu dans un match de
championnat du monde je crois qu'on n'a
jamais fait pire que ça
non mais ça y est ça y est qu'à sport
est dans la boîte à idées de la boîte
est ce qu'il peut faire de la pause la
partie on ne peut pas pas perdre par
contre alors sur food et 4 qui est quand
même la case où le fou a envie d'aller
faisant fodé comme il ya trois des six
et non moi je dirais plutôt qu'il ya
tour à 4 1 tour 4 au 6 mai ouais ouais
ouais ça fait nul loin tour à 4 alors
évidemment on ne commande plus cette
finale puisque ce sont deux joueurs de
génie qui connaissent parfaitement ce
qui se passe et surtout à 7 ce serait
une gaffe par contre et louga surtout à
7 tours prend une petite seconde je
finis avec ça ouais ça c'est nul ça
c'est complètement nul
c'est pas facile quand même parce qu'il
a tous russes 3 qui coupent leur ont
tous rêvent trois coupes le roi mais ici
on joue le geste technique roi au sein
explique tour efficace qu'on repasse le
roi et c'est très facile donc ici ça
c'est une petite parenthèse
nous revenons sur la pression ces deux
n'a pas été joué garry kasparov a joué
les divers chronique à jouer tour à six
et la kasparov réfléchit c'est très très
chaud il ne passera pas le coup qu'on
n'avait pas envisagé mais on avait
peut-être envisager une variante qui
marchait aussi
oui je pense je pense également disons
que la grosse gaffe de kasparov cette
date le pion au hk maintenant chaque
fois qu'il ya sous des capes ceux qui
ont acheté la deuxième reprise
et ça ça ne va pas une occasion gérard
of a fait une gaffe colossal il aurait
fait on va bientôt là gavera à une série
de grâce c'est possible
c'est possible il va il va peut-être
perdre ça fasse comme il le fait souvent
mais m'ont donné son visage se décompose
et il va faire des non de la tête
tout à fait ce trio a créé voilà
lalalalalala il se rend compte il se
rend compte il se rend compte que
sparrow fla
kasparov est en train de se rendre
compte qu'ils viennent de faire une
bourde il vient de faire une bourde il
avait réussi à obtenir une position qui
semblait avantageuse voire même gagnante
et là il a poussé son pion h4 un petit
peu trop rapidement la cagade la cagade
de kasparov
aïe aïe aïe aïe
kasparov dans la boîte il avait réussi à
se créer une position avantageuse et il
fait une erreur au 47e coup h4 qui donne
une opportunité en or à kramnik de
forcer la partie nulle et donc de garder
son avance au score avec les pièces
blanches dans la prochaine partie ce qui
change complètement les données au lieu
d'égaliser
kasparov et dans la boîte la cagade rien
bibi
incroyable en quelques coups là il ya eu
des revirements et moi kravets c'est
certain c'est très improbable
complètement incroyable ce qui s'est
produit c'était une partie à
rebondissements vraiment dans tous les
sens les rebondissements c'était très
impressionnant
non je pense que garry kasparov a bien
géré mais il n'a pas su après le 40e
coup reprendre son souffle
on l'a vu surgir tout de suite après
quelques coups pour revenir à
l'échiquier il voulait en finir très
vite ils voulaient pas perdre de temps à
gagner cette position gagnante et il
s'est précipité et il a fait la faute et
crame nick a su saisir sa chance
alors maintenant attention puisque c'est
pas la première fois qu'on se risque à
dire des choses absolument fausses et
c'est possible que nous soyons
complètement dans le faux mais je ne
crois pas puisque la la tête de castres
europe semblent confirmer ce qu'on
pensait
c'est à dire il aurait fait une gaffe
monumentale énorme
mais oui
direct les spurs qui ne bougent plus
qu'il ne restait rien elle peut jouer au
s2 peut-être un fief de c'est un coût
possible mais après tours 1
ça ça chauffe on peut envisager au f-22
mais après tours 1 c'est très très
difficile qu'est ce que tu jouerais à
pretoria stéphane je ne sais pas
la menace c'est ces 2 et wii l'option
ces trois avances l'annoncé 2 c'est une
grosse menace des rouages de est
impossible puisque le football est en
prières c'est vrai et si on revient en
d4 maintenant eh bien c'est la même avec
un petit peu plus de couleurs on peut
même jouer cavalier ou trois échecs
trapon prendre le plus âgé qu'elle et
trois échecs pour prendre l'option jets
d'eau c'est possible également qu'est ce
qu'on va jouer on ne pouvait pas il est
venu en d4 ça y est ça y est hahaha
il y est complet il y est complet alors
nous allons vérifier la finale deux
tours très vite à moins qu'il propose
lui la presse au cou mais je ne crois
pas fou des quatre échiquier de
démonstration ou alors on attend que
craint microbienne de toute façon on va
le voir à tête il attend chronique
peut-être qu'il attaquera munich on va
voir ce qu'on avait regardé dans cette
position après fou des quatre tours à 4
ici on ne voit pas d'autre ou que foot
français 3 ou en tout cas pas vraiment
et sur faut se prendre ces trois cas les
princes et rois tour prend un tour prend
hk de cette fondation est nul qu elle va
les prendre tour prend pour point de 4 à
vérifier la position est théoriquement
nul c'est effectivement
ça ressemble à une partie archi nul
stéphane alors là ça y est mais vraiment
c'est un acteur tous ces retournements
de situation et là ils avaient elles
sont envoyées tour incarne bien joué et
ramené à 3 g nick a tout vu la céramique
a tous vu à l'aller il a jeté un oeil
aux syndicats ils sont devant ils ont
tous vu c'est nul mais ouais bah c'est
la fin de la partie
akram dit à regarder castan o filho 10
nuls non il n'y a pas d'idée us et
kasparov qui doit prendre ses kasparov
qui doit proposer mes chroniques lui a
suggéré de proposer non il va ya 26 ans
en famille qu'est ce qu'il va jouer dans
cette position mais il va gagner en rien
de rien de grave ni travail ni drôle ni
nitya ils n'arrêtent pas de proposer nul
kasparov s'énerve plan d'achat louise à
l'alien crois pas il cédera pas énorme
il a traduit dire c'est à moi de
proposer nul il en train de lui dire
attends je vais aussi qu'il
n'atteindrait pas 80 croyable variable
dans les pas de coûter à simplement
kasparov est en train d'expliquer accra
nick setta a fait son show non mais il a
raison a tancé - quel point de plus il
ya nul c'est moi qui décide c'est pas à
toi tu proposes nuls bon maintenant
cramique et s il dit c'est tellement
faire annuler dans cette position que
pour lui ça lui paraît tellement évident
avec la tête de kasparov alors c'est
impossible ou pour les blancs de gagner
ça a l'air de rien mais il faut que les
blues jouent ça ça va énerver crâne et x
a de quoi ça ça l'a énervé comme dit que
je pense peut-être que kasparov laisser
d'énergie chronique c'est possible en
tout cas on a fait des images d'hervé
place par ofi boude et il est très très
énervé il boude kasparov boude
il est pas content chronique
est en train de rapper en fait kravica
était irrévérencieuse voit la chronique
a été dit révérencieux c'est à peu près
le mot et oui surtout reste 3 milliards
us 5
alala kasparov dans la boîte halal
kasparov qui qui est dans la boîte
il faut
d'instinct
voilà donc la
eh oui
kasparov a raté quelque chose
probablement dans cette finale une
partie à rebondissements alors un moment
donné une chronique on a l'impression
qu'il était peut-être légèrement mieux
que tout cela il ya une chose qui est
sûre c'est que kasparov le seul coup
qu'il peut jouer c'est tour air tran huy
sinon si le roi arrive en face du pian
c'est terminé si le roi se met face aux
pions sans cesse pas l'impression de
fizi dans les toilettes froid bien on
est en droit et après tout le fait
chronique alors là bas il va jouer
kasparov là alors chronique là ne va pas
commettre la faute de jouer tempo c'est
à dire que attestant prenez ça mon
travail il remet ça montre kasparov
qu'est ce que ça montre ça veut dire que
pour lui la partie est finie que c'est
nul c'est clair travail le cx2 on le
sait tous et 6 nuls mais se réjouit
électronique la chronique connais ça ici
joué salle aveugle les yeux fermés
chronique savait faire mieux dans cette
position quand il est allé cinq ans oui
non il arrive un peu après il le sait
encore peut-être pas à cinq ans ah là là
il est très doux et très doux mais
peut-être à 6 ou 7 oui c'est vrai que
c'est une position qui théoriquement et
nul ne devrait pas poser et dont on
connaît exactement les plans pour faire
nul
il va jouer roisin ou alors non non il
va jouer je vous la tour je pense que je
voyage pas un ange aura cadre il faut
pas laisser pu relancer
ah oui courage 5 qu'est ce qu'il a dit
là encore proposé nul
maintenant ces chroniques qui qui fait
mon entourage 5 c'est bien joué de la
part de chroniques
l'idée est la suivante il menace dans
cette position des étoiles 5 et sur wave
ii alors on va montrer le chic et
démonstrations lasser c'est clair qu'à
ce barrage mais tour f3 pour couper le
roi kramnik et sur chronique à jouer
après six tours h5 courage c'est sûr
avec deux taux refi 5 c est sur wave ii
n'en ont pas tous rêvent 5 puisque ça
perdrait certains prêtent au protour
airways 3 voilà c'est ça sur wild 2 ici
il faut jouer tous rangés 5 donc gsm
gagnant un temps avec une nulle
immédiate puisque là il n'y a plus de
coup pour kasparov pour éviter la nuit à
6 6 et 6 kasparov a peu bougé la tour
oui il peut jouer les banques peuvent
être là tout rond et fuite par exemple
est par exemple
kasparov peut encore mettre là tout est
fluide bon a priori c'est nul a priori
c'est du jeu il faut faire attention
parce que il faut pas échanger les tours
avec non mais bon c'est une finale
technique qui est pas la porte et non
plus du débutant
c'est pas facile à jouer il ya quand
même plus pour les blancs mais elle est
théoriquement nul et ces joueurs là
savent comment faire nul personnellement
je serais sûrement capable de faire des
fautes mais vous dire ça fait tout de
même très certainement très certainement
très certaine maintenant c'est vrai que
cette position est connue pour faire nul
non non c'est cette position doivent
faire nul cette pollution n'est pas
connu
comme tel puisque c'est une position
assez atypique le roi a coupé le pion et
angers 2 certes il n'a pas encore avancé
ça devrait être nulle enfin vu la tête
de kasparov c'est nul a de toute façon
chronique à mon avis la zone du
président non mais kasparov il va jouer
alors que l'ordinateur donne un net
avantage aux blancs à noter qu'en finale
deux tours il a encore bien des progrès
à faire
oui c'est pas c'est peut-être pas le
meilleur 1 quand on a donc là donc là
donc là effectivement positionne
théoriquement nul que kaspar on veut
vraiment jouer encore quelques coups
parce qu'il est énervé
et quand on est énervé on n'a pas envie
il va jouer le plus comme g6 c'est un
problème c'est quand qu'ils auraient
mangé si je crois non mais non mais là
le problème
il faut pas que le roi 2k sports passent
devant le pion non c'est pas si facile à
faire nul c'est pas si facile mais g
nick a certainement vu plus loin
non mais attention sur wii ouais c'est
je pense que j'ai vu à peu près comment
faire pour ramener quand même pas l'air
trop compliqué on peut repasser
l'échiquier de démonstration je pense
avoir trouvé le plan mieux dans cette
position après roy f2 il faut jouer tour
g5 kasparov va jouer un tour f 4 nos
portes lequel par exemple tout acte iv
maintenant on amène le roi sur la case
de 5
et là j'ai 30 ans je peux faire de la
lumière kremlin il faut mener leur
urgence sur l'a13 l'a10 à tours f5
cellule directement voilà à tour g5 joué
par cramique immédiatement oui il ya eu
aucun bluff tour f8 touré fuite je vais
pas casser par un problème chronique va
jouer trois de cinq ici et c'est réglé
c'est réglé après 5 s'est réglé il n'y a
plus de plan pour kasparov ne peut plus
rien faire il suffit de jouer un rôle de
5,04 et c'est une nulle instantané je
pense que ça va être conclue à près de
5,2 g nique
l'idée c'est quoi c'est de bloquer
l'avancée du roi c'est ça sert si le roi
blanc vient en f3 alors on peut montrer
c'est le brave la mnef troyat torres 5
échecs c'est nul alors attention parce
que là il faut faire très attention là
nul peut être conclu d'un moment à
l'autre
wen avait raté les images
oui tout à fait on va essayer de nous
allons reste pas montré l'échiquier re
ste bien joué et crame nique on va pas
entrer l'échiquier évidemment ici
vraisemblablement la semblablement c'est
le chaos pour kasparov
il ne peut plus gagner il en est sûr il
va probablement tendre la main à krainik
d'ici quelques instants
voilà la préhistoire en fait à la qui
est un trend à les soutenir dans sa
mémoire pour voir s'il n'y a pas
quelques pièges qui lui reviennent avec
les idées il est dépité un vraiment dire
d'affaires il va pas tarder à proposer
lieu il est dépité il est dépité le
kasparov fils avait la victoire en poche
là qu'est ce qu'il a fait de la voile à
seissan la main ça y est c'est fini
c'est fini terminé et la chronique il
explique ensuite gentiment voilà dans le
crâne il les suit pourquoi elle avait
proposé nu la casse par se détend
maintenant voilà hélas comme à son
habitude l arbitre vient récupérer la
feuille de partie des joueurs les
feuilles signé voilà donc ça se termine
assez bien alors que kramnik donc avait
proposé une nulle à kasparov alors qu'il
avait un pion de moins évidemment ça se
fait pas c'est celui qui a le plus en
plus qui doit proposer
il a après quelques coups kasparov s'est
rendu à l'évidence il ne peut pas gagner
cette finale avec un pion de plus c'est
une finale qui est nul
voilà donc très très belle partie cette
troisième partie kasparov a sorti le
grand jeu il a réussi à mettre kramnik
sous pression cramique a réussi à
remonter dans la partie et a
probablement prendre un peu
d'initiatives mais s'est fourvoyé et
kasparov en a profité
clairement malheureusement il aurait
fait une imprécision le coup h4 au 44e
coup le coup h4 probablement et le coup
qui empêche kasparov de marquer le point
et ça ça va faire un coup au moral du
champion ça va pas être facile de jouer
maintenant ça me dit avec les noirs
contre cramique qui mène toujours dans
le match
une victoire à zéro il a réussi à
contenir kasparov aujourd'hui alors que
c'était évidemment le jour de la
revanche de la dernière partie samedi
kramnik joue avec les blancs dans cette
quatrième partie avec la menace très
forte de marquer le point et donc de
prendre le large dans ce match alors
très bientôt la conférence de presse des
joueurs donc des micros des micros hf
vont être données aux joueurs une fois
que évidemment les joueurs se reposent
un petit peu ensuite ils vont revenir
sur la scène pour faire une petite
conférence de presse avec des micros qui
vont leur être donnée donc évidemment
diffuse cette conférence en direct elle
est ensuite archivé vous pouvez donc la
consulter demain et vous pouvez
consulter dès aujourd'hui les deux
précédentes qui ont été faites mardi
dimanche dernier en cliquant sur les
archives et vous avez aussi la
possibilité de suivre dans la foulée
après la conférence de presse le résumé
de la partie par danny king en anglais
suivi d'un résumé en français de 26
minutes de résumer de 26 minutes qui
sont donnés après la conférence de
presse en direct et enregistrées
disponible en différé dès demain matin
voilà très joli troisième partie la plus
longue pour l'instant la plus longue
depuis le début de ce championnat du
monde kasparov krainik kasparov crâne
nique avec pour l'instant cramique qui
mène aux points 1 0 et une partie
aujourd'hui à rebondissements
une très grande partie où on a cru que
kasparov allait revenir au score
voilà vous avez suivi ce direct je vous
rappelle que tout de suite vous allez
avoir droit à la conférence de presse
des joueurs suivis par les émissions en
anglais et en français de résumé de la
journée
qu'est ce qu'il ya voilà donc
très vite les joueurs vont revenir sur
scène pour cette conférence de presse où
on va enfin de comprendre mais pourquoi
et comment les joueurs ont raté des
coups ont trouvé des coûts dans cette
position en tout cas il est clair que là
semble-t-il kasparov a raté a raté de
revenir au score dans cette partie
hélas cramique a clairement réussi
vous êtes en direct ici sur canal web
pour assister aux championnats du monde
kasparov travnik troisième partie
viennent de s'achever par la nul après
des rebondissements épique kasparov a
raté le gain contre kramnik erreur au
44e coup oh non pardon aux 47e coup le
coup h4 a probablement était la faute
qui ne permet pas à kasparov de marquer
le point dans cette partie et chronique
reste avec un point d'avancé et les
blancs dans la prochaine partie alors
que les champions rejoignent leur siège
et on va tout de suite écouter leur
réaction après cette phase coin super
veilleuse troisième partie voilà je vous
laisse en direct cloud france culture
avec les champions conférence de presse
qui sera disponible demain matin en
différé sur canal web en cliquant sur le
bouton archives au new england training
jf
des music store
matti shaba ni moscou ni kiev rignac des
tâches ips et ipt acosta il n'y en a pas
un gros but est d'avoir un satellite sur
cette note une inquiétude
cliché quand j'entends crémation